dave's in fort worth texas
hi dave how are you mr ramsey i'm doing
fine thank you for asking sir
um your your time is valuable so is mine
so i'll make it quick
okay um i
me and my wife just found out we
inherited 315 000
whoa it dope yeah it doubles every 10
years
and of course like every every other
normal
i guess silly american we have debt bad
debt
um we have
we owe 150 on our house we have eight
thousand dollars on a credit card debt
and
some student loans basically it totals
out to be in almost 200
000. so that would leave about 150 or so
in the account
but the thing is we want to use that for
a retirement because we can get more out
of
that than we can my retirement at work
so i was wondering if you would endorse
the idea of
instead of paying off the house of
course we're paying off by the other
debt that's silly not to pay that off
but
15 off the house we put 50 000 down on
the house and refinance it to a lower
rate
and then we just slowly pay that off
whenever
uh and it gets paid off when it gets
paid off yeah how old are you guys
uh i'm 33 my wife is 26.
how long you been married
five beautiful years and we had the only
way
only way we're leaving each other is to
death sir okay i wouldn't wouldn't
question that
trying to figure out where you are okay
yes sir i know i'm just very
very excited yeah so uh who passed away
who left you the money uh it was her uh
grandma and her dad had her granddad had
uh was really good with money and they
left it to her
which of course me marrying her she
signed it over into both of our names
okay and cool now we're here okay
so number one let's back up a second all
right it
an investment doubles uh there's a
little nuance in mathematics called the
rule of 72s
and if you've if you divide the rate of
return from your investment
into the number 72 it tells you how
often it doubles so if you take
if you put if you say i got 10 on my
money your money would double every 7.2
years so
if you're telling me it's doubling every
seven years that means every 10 years
then that tells me it's invested at
seven percent
okay that makes sense that's what that
tells me so um
number one it's not doing really great
in an investment there
uh in good growth stock mutual funds you
should make considerably more than that
if you invested it the way we taught you
but um so the question is not what i
would endorse the question is
what what causes you guys at 50
to be in the best financial condition
to have the most possible money which of
these strategies
and that's the way we look at it right
yeah i mean it's the math of setting you
guys up
well in the future so what i would do if
i woke up in your shoes is i would pay
everything off
and i would use the fact that you have
no payments
to become an aggressive investor then
and so i would max out all my retirement
accounts
401ks roth iras anything i can do
uh do some other investing i would
increase my generosity
uh the downside the problem with that
idea
is you you
and your wife have handled money
horribly yes sir and if you keep
doing that after you pay off everything
you're going to wake up at 50
back in debt yes sir if you keep making
the same stupid butt decisions
now i used to make stupid butt decisions
that's how i can recognize them
because i got a phd in stupid and so
phd and dumb right so i i know what it
feels like
so the problem is you have to change
your behaviors
as a part of this advice or the advice
is wrong
if you're going to continue to handle
money like you're going to continue to
handle it
i would recommend staying in debt
that way you won't get further in debt
you know but if you'll do it right
and take those old house payments and
old payments that you don't have anymore
and use them to grow then you're going
to be fine and that's what i would tell
you to do
yeah and i think that will make granny
smile grandpa
smile from heaven and say hey these kids
are out of debt
and they are on a budget and they're
never they raise their right hand
put a brand in there take a tattoo
whatever you want to call it where i say
i never
never never never will dishonor my
grandmother
grandfather's memory by going into debt
again because i you because i misbehaved
yeah because there's a process that you
are refined when you go through baby
step two
and you've made you know decisions to
that you and your family are in debt you
work the progress in the program to get
out of it there's sacrifice involved
and through that sacrifice majority of
people at the end of it are like oh
never again i've made it through i've
trudged through this this problem and
i'm done
i'm never looking back and for you guys
you guys were handed a gift
dave and that's not a bad thing i don't
think that that's wrong no at all
and that's a blessing but exactly to
your point the refining that people had
through that process of baby step two
you guys are skipping that and again
not bad but recognizing and
understanding that that yes those habits
that you guys have had
have to break you have to change the way
you're viewing money and you you and
your wife sitting on together and doing
that
and then just on the more tactical side
of it you guys are young
and so the whole idea of the retirement
you're gonna have plenty of time plenty
of time plenty of money for retirement
yeah what i would just prescribe to you
and make you worth 10 million dollars
that's right that's right so paying
everything off
there's this this level of like oh you
get you get a redo
not everyone gets like the get out of
free jail card and you did and so
use it properly get rid of everything or
all the debt
and then you guys together continue to
work the plan
and then that money that was left it
will grow and you guys will continue to
contribute more yeah
so i i if i were in your shoes that's
what i would do
but i would be so afraid of myself
because of what we're talking about if i
were in your shoes i might even like
write out
you know type it out on your computer
print it out a contract
with myself and both of you sign it
that because we did this in order to
honor the memory that this inheritance
comes from
we are we are pledging to always do a
budget we are pledging to
always live on less than we make we are
pledging to always be
uh generous we are pledging to never
under any circumstances
for any reason ever borrow money again
and write it out and both of you sign it
and uh you know and then if you ever get
like you know
i gotta buy you we need a better car
and you start whining and you start
getting then you get that piece of paper
back out and you go uh-uh
no no because if you don't do that so
let's do this
i'm going to give you a gift to go with
the inheritance it's a year's
subscription to ramsey plus the two of
you go through financial peace
university
the two of you get on your every dollar
budget and wait 60 days to do anything
with this money just park it to the side
pretend like you don't have it
and do this stuff for 60 days and you
can give yourself the confidence that
you are going to change instead of this
just i promise i'll do it to myself
thing you
i would want to know that i wasn't going
to screw this up if i were you